president Nana akufo addo is under
pressure
this is the second protest against his
government in as many weeks
the triggers are out of control
inflation and a depreciating currency
Martin cable campaigned for the
president in 2016. today is an organizer
of protest against the government
times are hard in Ghana extremely hard
we have a cost of living crisis prices
have doubled some have tripled you know
and the first of the the price of petrol
is also gone through the roof
demonstrators say they want only one
thing
has two more years before the end of his
second term the maximum allowed in Ghana
ironically the criticism some people are
making against this government are those
that He campaigned on before he got
elected six years ago
you know what government supporters
brush aside call saw the president to
quit I Just Disagree that whilst the the
rights to demonstrate is protected that
your reason for demonstration must be
justified
with the IMF facility government is
negotiating still weeks away it could be
a long difficult Journey to the end of
the year for ghanaians Ahmad Idris Al
Jazeera Accra